in questa notte di sole Cosa ne pensa di
Rosa chemica mi è piaciuta molto È un
maschio Avete visto Rosa Chemical No sei
tu io a Lucia questa notte di sole e
furore la morte ha un preferito in gara
No la morte non ti fa per nessuno Spero
solo che muoiono tutti Rosa Chemical
anche lei deve morire ma è lui Lui mi
piace che sono pervertito Se metto il
rossetto in ufficio il lunedì gli è
piaciuto Rosa chemica Sì è veramente io
la sposerei per un uomo
in questa notte di sole furono
ideate qui è fluido Ma non puoi parlare
non parla prezzemolo Non sono molto
affettuosa se andassi a Sanremo Come si
vestirebbe un bel vestito nero con tutte
le linee di fuori e non solo quello però